Chris Mannix of Sports Illustrated their
senior NBA writer all right the rocket
strategy is what Chris and will it work
well their strategy it has to be getting
more guys involved I think that's for
starters
you know we've been consumed by this
referee debate over the last couple of
days calls non calls and some of it is
been it's legitimate I mean all season
long
that rule were you supposed to give the
guy space to land has been called the
plays were called over and over again
and then seemed to disappear and at
least in the first half of of that game
the other night but beyond that you know
if you look at some of the numbers and
up and kind of digging into this a
little bit that the last you know eight
seven or eight games of the the Rockets
Warriors postseason games the war is to
play the Rockets extremely well like
their offensive rating is down James
Harden's three-point numbers are down
all that means is that you can't have PJ
Tucker going for goose eggs you can't
have Clint capela giving you four points
Eric Gordon played well you know in
terms of number of points in that game
one but he was 4 for 13 from from beyond
the arc I mean I think there's there's
too much emphasis on unhardened and the
referees right now the supporting cast
for you has to play so much better if
they can have a chance in the series
yeah but you're bringing out all this
research now and going back to Game
seven of last year how is that gonna
help the Rockets tonight in Game two and
the rest of this series I mean it's like
a souped-up version of what Phil Jackson
did for decades I mean how many times
after you know Phil Jackson thought that
he didn't get the benefit doubtful calls
and playoff games whether it's for
Jordan or Jack or whomever did he gripe
to the refs I write about the refs take
the fine in the hoax back he would you
know to sway things one way of the abyss
is like to another level using advanced
analytics and and research about
complaining towards the refs I mean I
think it's kind of goofy especially the
stuff from last year given that you know
what if Huston missed 27 three-pointers
in a row in that game 7 I mean that
that's more impactful to me anyway than
a handful
missed calls I think it's it's all about
trying to make an impact on on the
referees and then he'll it's funny I
just saw that I think Scott Foster was
assigned to the game tonight and Scott
Foster has a long and checkered history
with Chris Paul and the guys from my
team and I I found that assignment it'll
be a time in our they you know they're
not made in the last 48 hours but that
just adds one's got a layer of intrigue
to all this well this is what I want to
know Chris this is what it comes down to
for me are the Rockets saying that
there's bad officiating or there's
favoritism to the rug to the Golden
State Warriors I think they're they're
saying it's favoritism because I mean
they're citing kind of specific examples
of how the Warriors get the calls and
and they don't so I think it's more that
than anything else but that's that's a
big accusation here sure I mean but
they're they're trying to to back it up
with data right I mean that's what
they're that that's saving them from
just being throwing around wild
accusations you're saying the league is
favoring Golden State they want a result
if you're saying that they favor Golden
State then they want that result that's
that's a bigger story here I would agree
yeah I mean I don't know there's any
other way to look at it then to say that
the Rockets are you know saying that the
NBA in favors Golden State or at least
the way Golden State plays I mean I
don't know if it's I don't know if
they're making the direct accusation at
the NBA wants Golden State in the finals
that's a lot but maybe they're accusing
them of favoring the way Golden State
plays he's Chris Mannix he's the senior
NBA writer for Sports Illustrated
joining us Dan Patrick show yeah just
trying to figure out how this goes
forward and also we saw this on the NCAA
tournament a couple of times including
the national title game where you get
guys trying to close out somebody and
they put their foot underneath or they
brush somebody when they're up for a
three-point shot it felt like the NBA
called this during the regular season at
least for James Harden
but now we get to game 1 against Golden
State and it didn't feel like it was
called the same way
you see though they make up they called
it all the time to the two maddening
effect on players who felt they weren't
interfering with the guy's space to land
now at times it's a difficult play to
call because players gotten better at
jumping forward
ATS playing their legs out at doing
things that will draw the contact rather
than just get the contact in that
situation but there were three examples
in the first half of Game one of that
rocket series where klay Thompson just
came underneath the legs of James Hart
and all season long that was a foul and
that to me is something I understand if
I mean forget the analytics up and
whoever the hell put the report together
or whatever but last year those three
plays in particular you can send those
the league off to say what's going on
here that should be called a foul you
did it all season long why is that not a
foul now that's where I think the
Rockets have a legitimate beef now I did
it's way the outcome of the game and you
can certainly say James Harden makes
eight of nine free throws and that's a
big a big difference but that that's the
one play I think that they have a
legitimate gripe when are the Lakers
naming a new head coach I don't know I
mean that I can't wrap my head around
everything Lakers have done the last
couple of weeks
I mean does it not strike you as bizarre
that in these coaches meetings are like
the Rambis 'as the buses and Rob polenka
like this is the the group that they're
sending out to meet with Monty Williams
it's getting to the point damn where I
can't believe I'm even thinking this but
if Monty Williams is given a choice
that's when Phoenix and the Lakers that
is I mean is it a choice the funds could
get the number one pick or even if it's
number two and you get John Moran you
finally have a point guard I mean is it
is it not a least a conversation yeah
what is the better job right now yes yes
if I'm Monty Williams and I can hold out
as long as possible until what may 14th
when the lottery takes place May 15th I
would make my decision if I had both of
those jobs if Phoenix wins the lot
or even has the number to pick I'd
strongly consider looking at Phoenix
then I would the Lakers if I'm Monty
Williams but it might be tyloo's job
anyway so that might be a moot point it
might be but think about what you just
said there for a second Dan this Phoenix
Suns team has been a coaching graveyard
for the last five years anyone that gets
hired there gets like a year plus they
have one of the worst owners in the NBA
in Roberts Arbor who thinks he's at GM
and medals in basketball decisions all
the time and yet we're still talking
about them being a better job than the
Los Angeles Lakers because of the
dysfunction that the Lakers have created
it really is mystifying that Jeanie buss
who was given a mulligan you know the
magic Johnson stuff was her Mulligan and
magic for all his failures did not leave
the Lakers in a state of disrepair that
she gets a mulligan and is somehow being
advised by Linda Rambis who has no
basketball knowledge to my to my
understanding and Kurt Rambis is sitting
in on basketball operations meetings and
coach meetings and his coaching
experience is basically two years in
Minnesota were disaster III don't if
your money Williams and that contingent
came out to meet with you I would have
some serious questions about the
direction of that franchise I'm also
wondering the fallout from the NBA draft
lottery
let's say the Knicks don't get the
number one pick let's say that they're
gonna end up third is there dudes Ione
Williamson officially signed with an
eighth like he can't say hey I don't
want to go to that team like he could go
back to Duke is that a foregone
conclusion that he has signed and he's
you know got an agent he's making money
or whatever it is and he can't go back I
don't know what he's taken financially
in the last you know couple of weeks can
I believe sign with an agent and still
go back to school at the NBA's changed
those rules significantly over the last
couple of years I'm sure it depends on
you know if he's taking a big signing
bonus that got in the car that probably
knocks it out of the equation but but
then in the NFL that happens not
routinely but it does happen the NBA
doesn't really happen
don't you know there have been players
that have scared off organizations Chris
s porzingis scaring off philadelphia is
one that jumps to mind recently for a
few years ago but more often than not
you know a guy gets drafted somewhere he
goes to that place if it's the sun's if
it's somebody else
Zions gonna go and play there does his
placement with the draft lottery affect
the free it does it affect Kevin Durant
does it affect Kyrie Irving in any way
if he doesn't go to the next does that
affect them if he goes to the next does
that affect him oh I think it has an
impact and I think it's premature to to
say that you know Kyrie would definitely
go or Kevin Durant would definitely go
or not go because of Zion but it's not
just the idea of getting Zion if you're
the Knicks you can take Zion or the
rights to Zion and flip it to New
Orleans in exchange for Anthony Davis
you can make that the centerpiece of a
Davis package and say to Kevin Durant
and Kyrie Irving well you didn't want to
come here with just the two of you and
maybe didn't want to come here if it's
RJ Barrett or some other top five pick
but now we have Anthony Davis and we
have you and we have Kyrie and we can
play in compete for a championship in
the next couple of years that's the next
biggest obstacle as they get ready for
free agency how can they sell especially
a Kyrie Irving maybe not Durant who may
have at least three championships or
half three championships by the time he
hits free agency but for Kyrie Irving
how do you sell him on leaving a Boston
team that is equipped to win over the
next few years to go to a Knicks team
that maybe isn't and having Anthony
Davis or at least the possibility of
acquiring Anthony Davis I think it'd be
a huge selling point it just seems like
Kyrie Irving's not happy Chris micronics
I well chronically perhaps I don't know
if it's you know specific to Boston
I really don't and look Kyrie the Kyrie
Brad Stevens relationship has been
interesting to watch the last
year-and-a-half because you know Brad
has gotten along with all the players
he's happy and he's gotten a lot out of
her a lot of the players but Kyrie is
the first player that has basically been
kind of an oil and water type makes you
because Kyrie came from and spent
formative years in a Cleveland Cavaliers
operation that basically didn't care
about the regular season that was
indifferent to it how many years did the
Cavaliers actually fight for a top seat
they didn't they didn't care about it
whereas Brad Stevens comes from the
school of let's get better every single
month let's get better every single game
let's build towards the postseason
that's been kind of a source of tension
between those two guys but now that
they're in the playoffs and you're
watching what Boston is doing like this
Celtics like maybe winning by 22 is an
aberration but the south is beating the
Bucks in four or five games is not
something that should shock anybody this
Boston team is really really good and
Kyrie is a big reason for that so I
think you're seeing you know exactly
what what would make Kyrie happy with
the way the playoffs are shaken out I'd
be more threatening this year than last
year oh yeah you have a closer and you
know end of game situations there's
probably not four or five guys in the
league you'd want with the ball in their
hands one in Kyrie Irving and you're
watching then in Indiana series Game
four and in parts of Game one the other
night Gordon Hayward is like 85% back
like he's he's getting there and when
he's out there and they've not able to
score but he's basically the point guard
half the time how many times do we see
Kyrie Irving off the ball in Game one
either posting up or going at Eric
Bledsoe I mean that's because Gordon
Hayward is out there in the floor and
create offense and you know for that
team but they're a much better team than
what they were last year they're far
more dangerous good to visit with you
Chris safe travels during the playoffs
we appreciate your time as always I dad
that's Chris Mannix Sports Illustrated
senior NBA writer a lot of energy there
I think the energy picked up when we
started talking about the Celtics then
the voice goes up a couple octaves their
former ball boy for the Boston Celtics
yes McLovin yeah it's weird he thinks
the Celtics are a real threat in the
East didn't see that coming yeah what a
shocker
he didn't mention now Ricky Rubio got
crossed over so bad early in the play oh
no he did not you did not if you missed
any of our interviews this week from the
mercedes-amg man cave or any week for
that matter go to the Dan Patrick app
where you can watch and listen from
inside the mercedes-amg man cave
mercedes-amg driving performance for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on VR live or download
the Dan Patrick show at